um i miss you my baby
no you're not just seeing things it's
really happening
i missed you aswell
finally reunited with his mom and i mean
she definitely showed her son how much
she missed him
just wait until you hear what kalani had
to say about it
oh my god
hey on the 90 day fans fam it's melisia
a swallows passionate reunion with his
mom
was just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to all of the jaw-dropping moments
on the latest episode of happily ever
after
i'm going to update you on all the
highlights kicking it off with
kalani telling asuelu how she felt about
that kiss
i'm feel so fabulous i finally see my
family my mom and my sisters
what do you feel baby um a little
awkward nice awkward like you making out
with your mom
no i shouldn't it was like
no it was not it was lip to lip mom
didn't kiss me like that we just
like this everyone else's awesome
asuelu continued to deny kissing his mom
on the lips and
eventually he just got really emotional
about it
and stormed off baby where we were
standing it was like this
no no jazz no we're just like this
okay well i'm telling you from where we
were standing
i don't want to do it it is such a cry
baby kalani did apologize
for hammering him about it and the
family went to go grab a bite to eat
but oof that's when the real drama
started to unfold did you bring any
money for mom
um i guess
now just to refresh your memory when
asuelu and kalani were back home
his mom and his sister started to
pressure him about
bringing a thousand dollars on the trip
as a gift for his mom
they said it's a samoan cultural
tradition
while kalani understands the tradition
she made it very clear that
they don't have that type of money right
now she's a stay-at-home mom
and asuelu works part-time so
as a couple they agreed to give a
hundred dollars
and some little gifts how much money
you bring for me
um
[Music]
i think a hundred
a hundred that's all that's a lot of
money
just hungry yeah special mine
very short mine now danny and his
parents
have a lot of money they will take care
of the kids
yes she said that and asuelu made it
very clear
that kalani's parents they do enough
while this entire conversation was going
on
kalani was sitting there trying to play
nice
but asuelu's sister said one thing
and kalani just could not hold her
tongue any longer
back home we gotta put our parents first
no matter we're married
we're supposed to take care of them and
send money no matter what
well do you send money home
it's not of your business it is
i don't like bring money to ruin our
relationship
okay tessie now whatever you
told me about that's okay but
i want to go home now i'm done
i'm done and she left
along with his sisters i mean this was
sad
my heart really goes out to asuelu no
one should ever feel like they have to
buy
love from their family all right well
let's go ahead and move on to our final
must-see moment which goes to the
explosive
fight that has been teased since the
beginning of the season
what no
hey you lied
what are you talking about look at this
what what bro look at this i can't read
it right
wait jess got a hand of vanessa's
information
by snooping through colt's phone she
then text her
and vanessa responded by saying yes me
and colts still talk
we actually talk every day jess come on
stop it you wanna be honest i don't
wanna talk to you
guys jess jess come on
stop it i don't wanna talk to you side
pause chat
stop fighting me stop you
chess chess where are you going
i went to my ex-house because you trash
i'm allowed to have friends
you know you care a lot what yep jess
was serious
she packed all of her bags and she
called a taxi
but what's really interesting about this
is that
colt had an ample amount of time to
either admit the truth
or apologize for lying but he didn't
can you just give me five minutes to
talk please i know what
i go to farm last day in brazil i got
spiderman because of trash
i'm not trash no trash because trash is
better
i'm sorry that that was funny but on a
serious note
just did leave and to make matters worse
this big fight is happening on colt's
last day in brazil
so i'm not sure if they're going to be
able to come back from this
yes they both live in the states but
jess is in chicago
and colt is in vegas so
this just might be the end me is your
mother
you must respect me next week on happily
ever after
asuelu breaks down as a conversation
about giving money to his mom
continues why are you hiding the money
if we send money to you i'll get my kids
every time all right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time